i'm gonna take a little break
more ice more ice more ice can we get
more ice what's going on everybody for
first week feast i'm shawn evans and
you're watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by the nigerian nightmare camaro usman
he's one of the best pound-for-pound
fighters in the ufc at dominant and
reigning welterweight champion who's
defended that title on four straight
occasions but how will he fare today in
a 10-round bout against the wings of
death
i guess only time will tell kamar usman
welcome to the show
thank you thank you it's a pleasure to
be here and i made sure i was hungry on
the ride here
so being of nigerian descent and being
born in nigeria
i'm accustomed to every meal having some
type of kick into it
you know i'm a little nervous with this
one because i've been on a diet for the
last literally six years
so i don't think my taste buds are the
way they used to be
now make sure that's this wing the one
to the far right yeah that's
that's important to know uh
[Music]
so you have a reputation for being one
of the best wrestlers in the ufc a skill
set that you started to build as a high
school standout and eventually as a
collegiate national champion and
all-american
i once saw you compare jiu-jitsu to
wrestling by posting a picture of a
cobra
alongside a bear for those of us who
have never done an arm lock or
been involved in a takedown in our lives
how do you explain that analogy
you know coming up in wrestling and
doing that for the you know earlier part
of my life
you understand that wrestling is kind of
like a bear there's not much you can do
when when someone just you learn how to
completely control and disarm somebody
else
brute force yes just just just basically
mauling someone
but then once i started to get into jiu
jitsu you realize it's not just about
mauling somebody anymore someone can
lure you to sleep
and catch you with something and now
you're tangled up in a pretzel
you have no idea how to get out and so
that's basically the analogy how i
compared them because jiu-jitsu was like
you can play the game you can kind of
just set traps and
be light be loose with someone all of a
sudden you got them wrapped up
they are they're going to lose their arm
or limb or go to
get choked unconscious so that was the
analogy between both is basically pick
your poison
[Music]
so a trick that i do with the flat i get
in here and i find these bones
hold it from the backhand we're going to
twist a couple of times
get that ball down now that's all me see
that we're not wasting none of that
nigerian so you gotta learn you know
over time you
so you don't waste any of that um
[Music]
a slight word what
i've heard you talk about having an
interest in the science of the mind and
when you say that you're reading
someone's body what do you mean by that
like can you really pick up on like a
physical difference between a fighter
who's confident and one who doubts
themselves
yes i can big time me my child
i like to break guys mentally i want
them to wilt that's what i want i want
to
break them internally to where after
this fight they will remember this for
the rest of their lives
and the biggest way to do that is
fatigue fatigue
makes coward of everyone and so i have
to be able to read them and see when
that fatigue is starting to set in
when someone's hurt there's certain
signs that they display like when the
fight starts
they're very active you can tell they
have this the scalp on their face and
that means they're they're activated
they're ready to hurt you and kill you
at any moment
but then when they start to fatigue that
scowl
slowly starts to go away the hands
aren't as high anymore they aren't as
activated
but these are all signs from these all
go signs once i start to see these signs
i start to step on that gas and i want
to break you inside
[Music]
remember the trick i just showed you so
let's look at that
look at that look at that clean didn't
waste no meat there you know
back in the day if you wasted this meat
in nigeria everybody look at you crazy
yo it's good food right there
find it find it there we go out of there
[Music]
the third one oh yeah i only got a
little bit but
smoky peppery yeah throughout the nose
too
so one thing that i've noticed watching
ufc events where you're not on the card
is that you have a very
polished broadcasting style and seem
very comfortable in the booth
who to you are the most fascinating
fighters to watch on tape like can you
give me one from the men's side and one
from the women's side
there's quite a few that's a tough one
right now
on the men's side i would have to say uh
francis in ghana because uh
kind of like a mike tyson it might be
five seconds
it might be five minutes but someone's
about to go to sleep
and that's the deal with francis and
ghana it's ridiculous the amount of
power that he has
it's almost unreal and so to watch a guy
like that
you're throwing hands on another human
being it's like you just have to see it
now as a female this is going to be my
teammate
my you know teammate that i've been with
now for the last
almost two years a year and a half rose
and i'm a eunice
who just recently regained her title ufc
261.
you watch her she's such a killer and
such a savage inside that octagon but
she's just
such a flower on the inside just like
sure
she'll cry like she cried in the cage
she cried before the fight
you know what a lot of people don't know
she'll cry backstage she'll like that it
takes a lot which it takes a lot for us
to do what we do
but she just wears it on her sleeve and
then she can
turn on that savage go out there and
kick you in the head unconscious so
i think those are the two special
fighters that i like to watch
[Music]
los caliente ah
i think they might have mixed up the
order because that last one kicked it
off yeah yeah
three spot does kick a little bit more
in this life unless you guys trying to
set me up
for the punch coming out for the next
one
so you hear boxers and mma fighters talk
all the time about
sweet spots besides the jar of the chin
which parts of the body are most
vulnerable to a kicker hook
the bread basket that's what they call
it's a famous term for
the stomach there's a region right here
in that stomach that little upper region
right above like right in the abs but
the lower abs
that it's it's very hard even when you
flex your abs
that spot is still penetrable you know
if you can land a good punch right there
and especially when the guy
exhaling it will sit a lot of people
down for sure
if you haven't watched my fights that's
one of the spots where i love to aim
just a body jab boom stick it there you
hit him with a good five or six of those
now they gotta they gotta basically
recalculate
why they got into this fight in the
first place and it doesn't have to be
hard
that's that's what you that's the
definition of a sweet spot it doesn't
have to be hard you could just
touch it it's like oh and you see
fighters when they when it happens they
try to
ah they make this face it's the craziest
face
and uh you just got to sit down you just
have to take a moment
and while you're sitting there hopefully
the fighter doesn't jump on you and
finish you
but then you have to think about like
man should is this really what i want to
do for a living
i don't know
ginger goat okay it's not bad
tamasa kicked harder than then
that's the first half sort of sneaky one
i think yeah uh yeah see i knew they
would set me up
i knew
we have a recurring segment on our show
called explain that gram where we do a
deep dive on our guest instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context so we'll show you the picture
over here on the monitor you just tell
us the bigger story
what was it like to hit the grammys with
burner boy and is there any special
reason that you chose his record anybody
to be your walkout song in ufc
it's crazy because music it really
speaks to the world no matter where
you're from what culture music
always speaks to the world like there's
there's uh chinese kids who can't speak
like english or lick of yoruba or
whatever
and they know the lyrics to all the
songs and they're able to sing it you
know so music just kind of transcends
culture and uh that's what brennan boy
kind of stands for
i see myself in a sense as as that being
able to do something
beyond just fighting beyond making money
that transcends culture and that's what
fighting does too fighting speaks to
everybody
you could be in a room i could be
teaching a fighter from moldova
a specific move a jab straight i don't
speak that language he speaks nothing of
english understands nothing
he understands this yes you know he
understands takedowns and
and submissions so you know we kind of
in a different sense but we're speaking
the same message all across the world
and him being and dropping that album
african giant that spoke to me big time
because i consider myself one of those
let's do it as you love
chica marsala it's a very popular indian
dish
and a little little kick on this one
oh it comes back oh
oh it sneaks back in there to apricot
so you once said the principles of what
martial arts were built upon are honor
respect and discipline
and nowadays we have guys who are solely
focused on the entertainment aspect of
the game
is this trend of like youtubers and
internet celebrities
invading the world of like pay-per-view
prize fighting
is that good for combat sports or not
good for combat sports
we live in this day and age to where
it's just publicity
good or bad as long as someone's talking
about you
which i never grew up in that you know i
grew up
watching muhammad ali and some of the
great things that he's done
and some of these great superstars
michael jordan and all these people
who it was never about just trying to be
famous
nowadays it's just not that it's not a
moral compass anymore it's just
i just want to be talked about and for
that purpose alone i mean it is what it
is if that's that was your
your that's what the idea was then it's
working but
that's just not something that i'm i was
ever really enticed by or intrigued by
this has got to come out sometime you
know somewhere
you know this has got to come out
there's always a second act to this show
yeah
it's gonna come out
so through the ages fighters have proven
to be great philosophers
and i get the sense that you're somebody
who respects the whole mental
side of this game so what i want to do
is hit you with
some famous fight quotes from famous
fighters and i'm just curious
how they hit your ear you know maybe you
agree with them maybe you disagree with
them maybe it reminds you of something
we'll just take it from there does that
sound good yeah sounds good
it's under my tongue so yeah it's there
it's it's it's just i'm sweating
once you've wrestled everything else in
life is easy that's from dan
gable yeah that's um
somewhat accurate statement but i
wouldn't say everything else
it's not that's not true it's still
tough parts
um do we have cold cold water
we got a pitcher pitcher full of ice
right there yeah i might just do the
pitcher
just go for the picture let's just just
go for the pitcher
in the midst of chaos there's also
opportunity that's from the art of war
yeah i like that quote because um
in the midst of chaos you feel like
everything is going crazy
there's still that opportunity for you
to be able to overcome it and prove
something to yourself
i feel like that made it worse
from mike tyson everybody has a plan
until they get punched in the mouth
absolutely this one is very very true
because um
in the fight game
we all uh you know you say what you
gonna do
you say what you can do and
wow and you know you you feel like oh
yeah i'm gonna
this is how i'm gonna attack this that's
how i'm gonna do this i'm gonna do that
a couple of times i've been in that
situation to where i had a plan of how i
thought this fight was gonna go
and then quickly you realize okay that
that's that's not what he had in mind
so now i come in ready to scrap i don't
care where it when it's
where it goes what happens i'm ready to
rumble each time
got a plan a got a plan b got a plan c
everything going on
absolutely all right speaking of
having a plan until you get punched in
the face are you ready to move on here
to the next wing it is the bomb beyond
insanity
i don't like the name
what did israel eat this israel had
three wings with this damn all right
let's go there
that's barbecue sauce that ain't bad
from health
oh oh
that's not barbecue at all no that's not
even a wink what is that
[Music]
it's just it's been described as poison
battery acid on this show
because it's not even like you only
taste the chicken have you ever seen
that shack face like that that
finger goes like that that was on this
one i was on this one yeah that only
tastes like wings that's
there's no chicken in there
that was nothing so according to
nigerian recipe writer yuan de como
lafay
there's a yoruba saying that goes the
soul that does not eat pepper is a dead
soul
does that ring true to you i don't know
about that i mean i think
why are we talking
[Music]
i think uh peppa gives a little extra
flavor you know
and it might have some benefits for the
body
but okay gotta figure out something out
here
yeah this one doesn't really
temporary
gotta do a one-two punch pop-up there we
go i'm learning here
i just yeah it suits it but when we talk
right back up
i've heard some dishes like suya and
pepper soup they can get extremely spicy
how would you describe the heat levels
in nigerian food
it's hot it's hot
more ice more ice more ice can get more
rice
we should talk like this with my mouth
closed
who made that [ __ ] why so it comes out
of kansas city missouri
rob my nose running see i knew you set
me up for some
[ __ ]
that's why you fought five and
four and five win nothing
it gets you kicked me with the three you
do a nice little lever punches the third
and then four or five is life so you can
mm-hmm
mm-hmm playing chess over here playing
hot sauce chester
yeah work with this guy
all right bro it's just not getting
better
i mean like my lips are burning that's
not happening usually
right
it's all going in um
it's like pouring gosh the one won't
fly
i wasn't easier
[Music]
coming in with ice we're coming in with
[Music]
ice
so before your ufc career i read that
you worked as a tour guide at the
olympic training center
did you have a favorite training center
fun fact or
item of interest on the tour when you
were a tour guide there um yeah when
people come in with all the guests come
in
we take them into the like there's a
theater in there
and we sit them all down and we uh
play this video for them looks like a
video
past olympic moments
but it got you so hyped when you come
out of that room watching that video
you're in the olympic spirit i was like
man i can bobsled
i can do this
sometimes i would just play the video
myself sitting there and
watching getting the olympic spirit made
me want to train harder and compete
harder
but we shouldn't talk when we eat right
you're telling me as you shake the last
one
[Music]
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last one
you don't have to you don't have to well
you don't have to
bro you go extra now come on
you don't have to if you don't want to
no but you can't do it
i have me not do it just got to be
surgical
all right let's see
you said as long as you touch the wing
right yeah yeah yeah
oh that's dry
i'm gonna do two drops just because
we've been going hard all right it's
true
that bomb was a bomb yeah cheers
cheers
i don't like the way you reacted to that
oh six years couple hundred episodes
never gets easier oh
why i swallow all right kamara usman
here we are
at the end of our main event we've taken
on 10 chicken wings and just one more
question for you before we send you on
your way
as we've learned today you have an
enduring spirit impossible to break
you've defended your championship four
times and show no signs of slowing down
do you put all of your mma wins all of
your title defenses on the same plane
or is there one fight or moment that
means more to you than the rest
put a majority of them all in the same
plane because
each and every fight presents a
different challenge
but i would say one of my favorite is
when this kid was jaw-jacking too much
talking all this trash saying that he
was gonna do this he was gonna leave me
on a stretcher
you know i'm donald trump's favorite
fighter i'm this and that and all of the
above
brought in religion talked about my
family my
former manager my current manager he
just did everything
possible than to go in there and
actually
physically break his jaw then knock his
ass out
was was probably one of my favorites
well you know what just like that
olympic video the hype
spirit i feel exactly the same way right
now
taking on the wings of death and living
to tell the tale
and now my friend there's nothing left
to do but roll out the red carpet for
you
this camera that camera that camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life
bro man um well i just ate all these
wings
and i know it's gonna have to come out
somehow so uh
[Music]
i'm excited i'm excited for that
challenge i'm excited to see what's the
next chapter what happens in my life
i'm just blessed to be in this time in
this day and age to
see so many things happening not just in
fighting not just in my life
but in the world i'm thankful
great job thank you great job
why who like who goes home and says yeah
i want the bomb on my wings
like no
oh [ __ ]
hey what's going on spice lords camera
guy bill here with a very special
announcement
june 14th is right around the corner and
do you know what that means flag day and
what better way to celebrate flag day
than by showing your hot ones pride with
some brand new
hot ones flags from buffalo's very own
oxford pennant
from the birthplace of the chicken wing
and the show that made eating the
hottest sauces known to man a global
sensation comes a collaboration for the
ages
the oxford pennant hot ones collection
is spice vote approved and shawn evan
certified
your favorite hot one systems are
immortalized in a series of pennants
camp flags banners and pins fully
designed and manufactured in my hometown
the spiciest city in america buffalo new
york
if there's one thing i love about
buffalo it's that it's giving you such
national treasures as the chicken wing
the buffalo bills
tony soprano's mom rick james camera guy
bill and the hottest collaboration of
the year
get yours today at
shop.firstwheefeast.com that's
shop.firstweekfeast.com happy flag day